[музика]
Привіт друзі Привіт З вами майстерня
творчості пані солі та гістенька
сьогодні ми будемо робити щось дуже
цікаве знаєте що це пташка
пташка Ми сьогодні будемо робити пташку
Це є дуже проста майстерка і дивіться
пташка може бути ось така або Ось така
вона може або летіти догори знаєте
крильми хати або навпаки зверху вниз і
зараз ми навчимося таку пташку робити
для цього нам потрібно дуже мало аркуш
паперу і фломастери або олівці або ручка
що маєте під руками Гаразд юстинку Навчи
мене робити пташку
перший Ми беремо куточок і його згинаємо
Доки не вийде трикутничок майже всі
майстерки так роблять так майже всі
майстерки починаються з того що ми
згинаємо Один кут так і чоловіки Що ми
робимо
відірваємо залишок так відриваємо
залишок вона потрібен квадрат Якщо у вас
є квадратний папір то вам нічого
відривати вже не треба нам треба щоб був
далі трикутник нам не треба
вати Отож У нас є трикутничок потім ми
згинаємо знову на Філ щоб був ще менший
так робимо ще менший трикутничок Давай я
вгадаю далі далі ще менше робимо
добре Ось зігнули трикутничок
так-так-так
потім ми беремо ось цей куточок і його
згинаємо Ага добре зігнули в один вікно
на іншій від перегортаємо і ось цей щось
згинаємо можна позаду можна можна піти
[музика]
у нас вийшла пташечка бачите там де ми
згинали ось тут нас Дзьобик Ось тут в
нас крильця Вона може летіти Ось так
може летіти Ось так такими кролими
махати зверху а може такими крилами
знизу Давай ми намалюємо дзьобики
щоб другим було краще видно
можна намалювати
пташок немає ротиків
можна ще розмалювати намалювати якісь
там пір'їнка Ось так
бачите клас Та можна ще пір'їнки тут
домалювати
раз два три
Ось так друзі Ось така пташка у нас
вийшла
Ну що ж будемо закінчувати
до наступних зустрічей друзі скоро
побачимось па-па
Привіт усім з вами пані Софія і мої
помічники юстинка і зайченя хрумчик
Сьогодні ми з вами послухаємо історію і
з такої книги яка називається коли друзі
поруч Можливо ви пригадуєте уже таку
А хто забув або не бачив історії
попередньої з цієї книги я вам нагадаю
Ця книга про друзів звірят які люблять
допомагати один одному і наша
сьогоднішня історія називається
киці потрібні окуляри каже старша киця
до меншої Ходімо
потрібно тобі перевірити зір
А хто буде його перевіряти здивувалася
менша киця лікар у магазині окулярів
відповіла старша киця він повинен
перевірити чи добре бачать твої очка
киця пішла до вітрини магазину окулярів
Як же багато їх тут тут було і круглі
окуляри і червоні і жовті і класичні і
навіть смішні окуляри цікаво що це за
такі смішні окуляри
у магазині оптики киці довелось Дивитись
крізь кумедну машину лікар міняв їй
лінзи і просив кішечку прочитати літери
написані на спеціальному плакаті
Ну що ж нарешті відповів лікар тобі
потрібно носити окуляри
доберіть у тобі красиву пару
нарешті окуляри були готові і киця
наділа їх О тепер я чудово бачу зраділа
маленька киця і вона разом зі своєю
старшою кицею вийшла і з магазину
наступного ранку киця не наділа свої
окуляри цікаво що ж трапилося давайте
послухаємо А чому ти залишила свої
красиві окуляри
запитала старша киця ніхто не носить
окуляри крім мене зітхнула маленька киця
я не хочу їх надягати
але кицю посміхнулася її старша Киця ти
ж так добре бачиш в окулярах вона наділа
окуляри наніс і сказала іди пограй
своїми друзями
киця пішла і її привітали її друзі Вітаю
А я і не знала що ти носиш окуляри
сказала мавпочка вони такі гарні
дзвякнув песик ой вони тобі дуже личать
підхопила зразу мишка
а я не хочу носити окуляри
запхинькала киця ні в кого з вас немає
окулярів крім мене носити окуляри Це так
безглуздо
Раптом у жирафа виникла гарна ідея
А якщо ми
і щось вони почали шепотіти
він щось прошепотів песику мишці
зайченяткові на вухо звичайно ми можемо
цікаво що вони задумали
і далі підійшов до киці жираф і каже до
неї Ти знаєш кицю це неправда ти краще
бачиш в окулярах тому носити їх
зовсім-зовсім не безглуздо Ось дивись і
раптом друзі киці повернулися до неї і
знаєте що показали що жираф мав на увазі
носити окуляри зовсім не безглуздо усі
весело засміялися знаєте що вони зробили
вони намалювали окуляри собі прямо на
обличчі тим самим вони показали що
носити окуляри Це круто
які класні друзі були у киці правда
юстинку Тобі сподобалась наша
сьогоднішня історія так
А вам малята Я сподіваюсь що так і хочу
вам пригадати що у людей буває різне
волоссячко різні очі і навіть у звіряток
бувають різні хвостики різні вушка але
це ж цікаво Правда ми усі такі різні
всіма різні але всі ми рівні
звичайною спинкою які чудові слова
пам'ятаємо друзі що Усі ми різні Але усі
важливі Ну що ж друзі будемо прощатися З
вами була пані Софія і мої помічники
друзі юстинка і зайченя хрумчик па-па
па-па
[музика]